So far, we've examined the basic structure of AJAX request alongside some
basic use cases.
We've used def tools to identify that Facebook and
Twitter use AJAX request to load content on the fly.
We've seen how Reddit and the Reddit enhancement sweep use AJAX request to
load data inline as users request information.
And, we've briefly taken a step back to examine how even big websites like Yelp!
Take advantage of external API's to add functionality to their website.
In the next part of the lesson, you'll be diving into building the moving
planner app which is going to integrate Google Street View in the background.
The New York Times API to give us these articles, and
the Wikipedia API to give us these articles.
For this quiz, I want you to spend a moment to brainstorm what kind of APIs you
could use to mix and match in interesting ways.
Take a look through the massive list of APIs in the instructor notes, and
take a moment to think about some kind of cool,
novel way you could integrate different APIs together in a single web app.
Once you finish your brainstorm, type what APIs you want to try out in this box.